Let's go next to our caller from the three
zero three area code.
Who's calling today from three oh three?
This is Richard.
Hey, Richard, what's up?
Well, I wanted to ask you tend to be a bit
become progressive.
I moved to Colorado about five years ago.
I think I have the political will to, you
know, go to any Senate and or congressional
committee and just, you know, make a pitch.
But my question to you, that goes farther.
That builds on what, minus what I just said
is that are you willing to go to the binding
campaign and ask that very question?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
So let me see if I understand you're willing
to go to the Colorado politicians and ask
them for things you want.
That was the first thing you said, right?
Correct.
OK.
What do you say?
Let me just see if I understand what you're
saying.
Am I willing?
Am I David Pakman willing to go to the Biden
campaign and ask them for something?
I mean, I'm want to be honest, I'm not a journalist,
so I don't have the schedule where the final
campaign will be from day in, day out.
I'm not that.
I'm not that focused on that campaign.
OK, sure.
Durland, I might as well just hand it off
that question to you if you're interested.
If you're not interested, I get it.
You have stuff to do.
But after being in the Denver protests of
getting tear gas and pepper sprayed, I wasn't
really a big fan of that.
So I did some deep dove thinking and I came
to the realization that maybe, maybe, just
maybe the DEA has become progressive.
What would it look like?
Who would it.
Who would run it?
Are there any agencies that will compound
on the DEA for scientific exploration?
What what could the DEA become?
What?
Rather than just being an enforcement arm
of the Justice Department.
And Richard.
Is this now.
Is this a different topic now than will I
go to a Biden event and ask him a question?
I'm sorry.
I'm just trying to keep up.
Well, I'm trying to sigger that answer out.
I'll let you decide if it's two different
issues.
But if you've got or if you're in the press
box exacta, have the opportunity to ask that
question.
Maybe.
Maybe it's the same question I don't want.
Maybe it's the same topic.
All right.
Well, Richard, let me look into that.
OK.
All right.
Thanks you.
Richard, we've taken detailed copious notes,
and we will we will investigate.